welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your insider on
the outsider and with one week until the
finale things are really ramping up in
the show episode 9 is the penultimate
entry and there's a lot to unpack from
it throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down all of the ins and outs of
the episode and its ending there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
anything ruined then I highly recommend
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel as the finale
is right around the corner and you don't
want to miss what happens in the last
episode without the way thanks for
clicking the video now let's get into a
breakdown of the outsider episode 9 okay
so episode 9 pretty much sets the
grounds for in which the finale will
take place it opens however in the past
all the way back in 1947 with two boys
John and George the episode has a boy
searching a barn similar to the farmhand
that discovered Terry Maitland's clothes
earlier in the series however this is
just a game and the two head off into
the woods eventually they end up
sneaking into a cave opening which just
so happens to be the cave that we heard
about in last week's episode of cave
stock this is the bear cave that due to
what we learn in this episode gets
renamed and this is why later in the
entry it doesn't show up on a map
eventually the boys become sealed in
there and a search party died along with
them after the cave collapses people did
try to save them but unfortunately the
machinery back in those days was not
strong enough and using explosives would
have caused the whole system to collapse
there were a large number of lives lost
that day and Al cuoco purposely chose
the location because of the grief that
was laced in the area we do know that
the creature feeds on despair of those
that have lost something they love and
this is why the cave was chosen above
all others we discovered that the Bolton
family aka Claude's ancestors were
members in the search party and that
four of them died in the cave along with
many more people because El cuoco has
caught memories the creature is aware
that this is the location of a tragic
event and there is more grief in the
area than the surrounding locations al
cuoco is once more in control and those
that try to enter its domain are doomed
this episode the theme of hopelessness
and a feeling that no matter what people
do they will always lose claw discusses
how the outsider wanted in and it got in
and there was nothing that he could do
no matter how much he tried how cuoco is
like a virus this is also given weight
when there's mention of the Spanish flu
of 1918 which also hit the area in case
you hadn't heard of it the Spanish flu
was a massive pandemic that took out 500
million people during the early part of
the 20th century the world population at
the time was only 1.9 billion so that
was a big hit on humanity El cuoco is a
cancer than not only ravages people but
the planet - and it looks like the group
are out of their depth so yeah nice
hopeful message therefore Monday morning
don't worry though
I believe in you I know you can make it
through the week anyway the outsider is
pretty much about breaking cycles of
oppression and victimization al cuoco
has been in a position of power for
centuries because of its ability to
control those around it whether it's the
slaves that it takes or the fact that
the police looked the other way 99% of
the time the monster very much
represents a system that allows it to
continue to do what it likes I don't
really think it's a metaphor for the
times of movement but that's the most
recent example that I can think of in
which a system was set up in a certain
way that allowed certain people in power
to do things that they wouldn't normally
get away with there really would have
been a feeling of hopelessness to a lot
of people who had to go through
situations that eventually led to them
uniting and speaking up and you very
much get the feeling that Ralph and Coe
are in over their heads we know that
they have united in order to help one
another and sinneth the aforementioned
movement al cuoco has survived for so
long because people would rather stay
out of things that could lead to trouble
this is exemplified by the fact that a
lot of people outside of it just don't
want to get involved in whatever is
going on and it really hammers home the
message that evil Rises when good people
refuse to act however as I've mentioned
with the group they are united and
tackling the problem together which
means that they can rise up and meet it
after the initial introduction which is
laced throughout the episode we jump to
Ralph's talking to the police and they
try to suggest a link between the boy
that was almost abducted at cave stock
and Frankie Peterson's murder they ask
the officers that they can interview the
family
and the granted permission in addition
to his memories we also learned that Al
cuoco has a psychic link with cord and
that in the best interest of the group
they should edit what they say to him so
they don't give away to the creature
what their plan is this link is how it
knew to follow Claude to another town
and whereabouts that he would be staying
the only way that we ever learned about
al CooCoo in the first place is because
Terry was shown on CCTV and another part
of the country and this started off the
entire investigation it doesn't want
this to happen again and this is why the
creature didn't just remain in Cherokee
City and kill someone there there's lip
service paid to the thing which is a nod
to the film and how that creature could
transform into people and out of all of
the episodes thus far I definitely feel
like this is the best due to its pacing
and the details that are uncovered ralph
is clearly now on board and he even
shuts down Howie for trying to question
the notion that the creature doesn't
exist just because they're accepting it
though doesn't mean that it will be easy
killing it they have no idea what this
really is or how to defeat it do you
know that they need to get Claude out of
the area as it's unsafe to be there
Jeanne doesn't sound too happy that
Ralph is staying and it seems that he
doesn't believe he's got much of a
chance either due to the fact that he's
smoking I'm probably reading into this
but just in general whenever I watch
something and see a character who didn't
really smoke suddenly doing it I always
kind of feel like in their head that
think they're gonna die soon people
often don't smoke because of the health
hazards that can lead to down the line
but when someone takes it up it always
shows to me that they know that it's not
going to be the thing that kills them
it's really subtle and again I could be
looking into it but let me know if it's
something you've also noticed in TV
shows and movies the team review the
footage and realize that all cuoco is
vulnerable hungry and desperate this
kind of reminded me a bit of when Ted
Bundy was in the run and he was
frantically taking as many lives as he
could I've already discussed the
similarities between al cuoco and serial
killers so I don't want to retread old
ground but you do get the feeling that
the show is deliberately having the
creature operate in a similar manner
from the interview Ralph and Cole learn
where the Beast is hiding we also
learned that the old guy is the
grandfather I know I said it was the dad
last time so am i but the son a
hairstyle should have given it away by
didn't and Ralph also brings up the
scratching and though it did look like
the grandad could have been cut last
week he denies it
so yeah draw your own conclusion from
that my wife said that he did get cut I
was a bit unsure but this kind of clears
it up he talks about I'll koukos face
and how it still looked like a mask and
how he include hid the best chicken
shack around we also learned that how he
is in anything man and the two have a
history in which how he represented
Claude for a fight at the club and eases
some of the guilt on the last shoulder
when he realizes that he wasn't bad
enough to be remembered from brother
Bolton they learn about a secret
entrance to the cave in the gift shop
and he also lets slip the cord about
that plan he did it for the right
reasons but now it knows that everyone
is on their way to make matters worse
our cuoco has a sharpshooter on his team
and that can take them down see your
Claude and how he head out to join them
but it looks like time is running out
for everyone the episode ends with them
caught in the crosshairs we wonder if
they're gonna end up dead we see him
take a leg out which is kind of a gutter
as he was gonna stay behind you to that
copper taste in his mouth and the
episode goes out with a bang
after several shots can be heard firing
now we did see a snake stalking jack and
I kind of have a feeling that this might
come into play next week and it could
bite him jack is also wrestling with
himself and trying to fight the
controller el Coco has over him but
whether this happens or not we will see
he obviously has no qualms about
shooting people but yeah I do hope that
he turns to the light in the end now for
the rest of the video we're gonna be
talking about what happens at the end of
the book we're just one week away and if
you don't want to know what happens next
week then I highly suggest that you turn
off now again this is big spoilers and
yeah if you if you don't want the show
ruined then thanks for checking out the
video till this point and hopefully I'll
see you next Monday anyway they managed
to make it past Jack and finally get to
the creature this was also shown in the
trailer for next week so not massive
spoilers there however Holly being an
outsider herself manages to track the
outsider in the caves and she kills it
with a happy slapper which is a sock
filled with balls she used this in the
Stephen King book mister Mercedes but
whether it happens here in our or we
don't really know as they have
mentioned the prior story with her in
the episode we also saw glory and
Jeannie talking face to face nose lip
service pay to the DA asking her to talk
with him though she denied his request
if the story follows the book the next
week he plays a big part in delivering
some good news that is that he drops all
of the charges against Terry Maitland
and he publicly announces that the CCTV
footage proves that Terry was not the
killer
the work does seem to be going that way
and Holly actually asks what the outside
his name is you also see Ralphy using a
stone deer hit something in the cave so
it could be him who is the one to kill
the monster that's pretty much the
majority of the plot but I do think that
next week we'll have some surprises
again this was another brilliant episode
and with just one more entry I can't
wait to see what happens now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
episode 9 and what you've thought the
season so far
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up and if you've missed any
episodes then make sure you check them
out in the playlist at the end every
month on the 15th we give away free
blu-rays and all you had to do to be in
with a chance of winning the Infinity
Saga box set it's leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us in our discord server
link below or a definition whitey on
Twitter those are the best ways to keep
up to date with the channel so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]